come on but there's a whole other world  of dragons out there what should we name  it itchy armpit it is I bet you think  you know a lot about dragons and I know  you every dragon has its secrets  I'll show them all to you did you know  about this that's your mother now you  know where I get my dramatic flair he  likes it something is coming something  had never faced before  what's down there no control the Dragons  Oh  buddy his fist with my face if he tries  to take my dragon huh  dad there's something you need to know  probably I know what you're gonna say  beautiful lost you what a team now what  do you want to do that  Drago's coming for our dragons you have  to stop him together  don't worry but I'm not gonna let  anything happen to you  you have the heart of a chief and the  soul of a dragon you know that doesn't  wash out  god damn down dragon riders coming  through  we can't fly these things that our  babies  distract the Alfa have a nice flight